and then came Game 10 on December 6th
2017 we've received the first 10 games
published between the 100 game match
that went down between the Google
acquired company deep mine and their own
alpha 0 and the world's strongest open
source engine that being stockfish your
mama told you to save the best for last
and if that's what you're expecting here
in our fifth and final video of this
series then we hope that you're gonna
get it a super instructive and
interestingly dynamic attack that went
down but don't take my word for it let's
let the moves do the talking after
Knight f3 Knight f6 and d4 we see a
transposition back into what has been
repeated in almost every game that alpha
zero had white and that was the queen's
indian besides the lone french we had in
game nine and after b6g 3 we see
stockfish sticking with the approach
that he adjusted to in game 5 and
repeated in game 8 that of course being
Bishop to b7 rather than the move Bishop
a6 that was played by stockfish in game
3 after Bishop b7 Bishop g2 here we see
Bishop e7 for those of you who have
followed the entire video series and if
you haven't by the way check out all the
videos and our twitch a video library or
of course on YouTube or chess comm
wherever you want to find it but we also
saw Bishop before check played in one
game by stockfish here the open source
beast decides to go back to the
classical development of Bishop e7 and
after castles castles we see white
employing once again the positional pawn
sacrifice that has been used several
times by alpha 0 he likes himself a
position upon sacrifice apparently the
point of d5 everybody is that after each
takes d5 Knight h4 again we see the idea
repeated that white is using the
diagonal to expose a pin against the b7
Bishop and if black doesn't play the
move that he has played every time in
this position c6 you have to guard the
pawn white would simply win back the
pawn for free and then grab a massive
space advantage not something black can
deal with especially with the dominant
Knight coming into f5 hitting the dark
square Bishop so not that we need to
explain it any more than we already did
in game 5
that's why black has to play c6 and
after we capture d5 and play the move
Knight f5 obviously we are not
interested in letting black take and
double the h4 pawns the knight comes
back to c7 and once again
efore is played and we are back in the
exact position we had
obviously now in that game black played
the move Bishop eith f6 that being
stockfish and we talked a lot about
White's different options specifically
around trying to make sure that white
gets very decent control over the D file
trying to make sure that those squares
are gripped for long-term compensation
on the dark squares specifically but
there were also some lines that occurred
for example in the trade-off game that I
quoted after rook e1 D v e5 and then
bishop CA trading off the knight for the
dark squared bishop this way so a
similar though not that exact line type
of compensation was achieved by alpha
zero and that he gave up two pawns for a
long term form of compensation on the
dark squares specifically related to the
dominance of this d6 square so I wonder
I'm talking about this because I wonder
how much stockfish is learning from his
previous experience of alpha zero maybe
doing a little organic machine
intelligence of his own or if it's just
a matter of wanting to mix it up but
here stock first plays the other main
line which is not Bishop f6 that of
course being d5 black is willing to give
up the dark square bishop immediately to
avoid any type of long term weaknesses
achieved on the D file and before we
think that okay now the d5 is played do
you think the most common ways to deal
with this break would be approached
would be the approach from alpha zero
those moves being things like Knight c3
usually white doesn't want to take here
because you want to increase your
pressure so that after Bishop f6 and you
take it you can leave blacks trapped
with an isolated pawn as long as you
have another piece hitting d5 if black
did take with a knight again you'd be
able to take it and you as like we said
bleeding black strapped with this
isolated pawn there are even some lines
that go with white immediately coming
back with the 93 and and trying to grab
the pawn this way or after Knight to c5
some of these variations are our
simplified very quickly and and and
reach a very very equal ending so this
is one way that white has played
previously rook e1 is also a move that
again builds on the tension maybe Bluffs
at the idea b5 we can even get a
transposition to the Trekkie buff game I
quoted if you're paying attention but
either way those types of build on the
tension not release it are the things
we've seen be the most common approaches
here but alpha zero doesn't want it
alpha zero plays each takes d5
immediately letting black take back with
the knight which of course dogfish does
because that's the whole point if black
doesn't have to take with the pawn and
isolate said D pawn why do it why not
take with the knight well that's
sock fish stinks and and agrees with
that assessment and after Knight to c3
we see that now we're getting even
further into roads that have still been
played I think there were a couple games
in the database but not nearly nearly as
much as the other lines were white build
on builds on the tension tries to play
against the isolated pawn in this
position after Knight to c3 stock for
surprises with the move Knight takes c3
and I say surprises because it's the
move that allows the next series of
forcing ideas by white to come maybe I'm
just saying that because you think after
stockfish getting it handed to him a few
times you'd have some human fear now I
remember he's not human
the other line I analyzed probably the
more solid approach by black is indeed
Bishop f6 and allowing isolated Queen
plumb positions to be reached
maybe call alpha zeros Bluffs Bluff
where the best line is probably just to
go for 93 and transpose into the line I
said that just simplifies so to me
Bishop f6 I'd be curious what alpha zero
might have come up with if it's not just
this big simplification maybe 94 maybe
something else to maintain the tension
but the world will never know kind of
like the center of a tootsie roll pop
because stockfish played Knight takes c3
and here's where things get fun if you
haven't paused the video or if you don't
have all the refreshments you need for
the rest of the time that's a you
problem
we're gonna move forward Queen to g4 I'm
not taking back on c3 and letting you
trade Queens I'm gaining a tempo on g7
and immediately saying that pieces will
come to the Kings side whether you like
it or not after g6 Knight h6 check King
g7 and take c3 we see that white is
getting compensation for the pawn in a
way that is not exactly like the
previous games we've seen that we're
focused around the back we're deep on
the pressure
excuse me on the on the D file the d6
square but still centered around the
Kings side and that seems to be a common
theme of all of these Queens in D and D
pawn sacks that
yes White's down upon here you can count
again the piece on the board if you
don't believe my math but we're dealing
with lack of development on the Queen
side and when you have lack of
development combined with your opponent
having a lot of pieces on the squares
that they want to be on you're always in
a human predicament where humans really
get afraid of those positions right no
one likes having their King come under
fire so we're assessing that alpha zeros
practical approach and and belief that
long-term activity will will make up for
the pawn that's clearly what what alpha
zero is saying is the right approach
against stockfish
not that any of us can repeat it but it
is an interesting takeaway after Bishop
to see a queen of four Queen to d6 and
then the Queen moves the move g5 comes
in and as you can see stockfish likes
this position that evaluation bar to the
left says well I think I'm kind of
trapping your knight which is why I was
willing to do that I'm not sure how much
compensation you get if you let me have
it but if you back up the knight
I'm gonna gain yet another tempo
followed by another aggressive move and
suddenly it may be black who's getting
an attack on the Kings side
don't forget the second player is up a
pawn so g5 was played and this was the
position that first really shocked the
world when reviewing these games because
I think Knight g4 would be the move than
any human would plan to play here and
again I've let bit stockfish been
thinking for a while now our engine on
chest calm still thinks 94 is the best
move still thinks that's what black
should should be expecting but no alpha
zero plays rook to e1 just giving up the
pony saying I'm gonna I'm playing for a
long-term peace sacrifice that's right
long term and peace sacrifice used
together no longer oxymorons and and I'm
pointing out that your development on
the queenside to leave something to be
desired as it did in previous games and
after King takes h6 I'm playing a move H
for building up on the attack slowly I'm
not going for anything super aggressive
by the way moves like check here just
don't quite work as now you can't afford
to take e 7 in the intermezzo because I
get the Queen first and if you take Chi
5 black I'll trade and then play Queen
to g6 pretty much defending everything
so nothing really do expect with Queen
checks rook takes e7 also would just be
a big way to trade which shouldn't be
something that you're into if you're
already down a piece so yes h4 makes
sense but it is kind of interesting to
see that it's again just building up
long term saying I believe that blacks
dysfunction would be so hard to deal
with I don't need to be in a rush I can
bring more pieces into it
f6 has played I did some analysis of
King to g7 just to show how potentially
dangerous the attack might be for all of
you
white would have taken on g5 and after
Bishop a5 the key point is that Bishop
f4 and avoid the Queen trade gets
followed by Queen e5 which is a double
attack and a fork on on the two bishops
white is gonna go on to have a very very
strong initiative and maybe even win
back some mature right away so that's
that's one reason why black chose to
play f6 now after Bishop e3 Bishop f5 we
get the rook over again we
see the the black attempt to try to get
the Queens off the board not interested
of course especially given that we're
down a piece we need to get something
against the king and after b5 takes g5
Queen h4 check in King g6 we see the
next truly brilliant move that flips the
even for stock fish evaluation on its
head and shows exactly what alpha zero
was intending the whole time plays Queen
to h1 putting the Queen back on the
first rank like he's Anatoly Karpov and
saying that even here with my pieces
retreating your development on the Queen
side lacks so much and there's still so
much to be desired there that I'm really
not in a rush what I find even more
fascinating about Queen h1 is not even
the patience it shows but the follow ups
that come with it the key ideas and I'm
going to try to show you some of the
lines I've analysed King g7 was played
in the game but I'm gonna show you what
happens on h5 as that is initially the
first move that stockfish likes you can
see the evaluation going liking black
and it seems to be good but one really
fascinating idea that we found is that
white is consistently just offering a
trait just trading pieces to open
Appliance and after Queen takes a to
Bishop to d4 again just bringing more
pieces into the attack and saying that
despite all of the the material here now
you start to see even stock fish liking
white note that there is no development
of this Knight which means there's no
development of the rook the knight can't
come to d7 because the bishop takes f5
followed by Queen takes c6 check and
everybody falls if the knight goes to a6
then similar things happen with Bishop
takes f5 so yeah in hindsight we all see
that wow yeah it really is hard for
black to coordinate but going for the
SAC initially just seems so risky after
Bishop after Knight to d7 ok we have
exactly what I said take a 5 but the
main move I analyzed not the bad move 97
but Bishop d6 and this is where things
get really really fun this shows you
just the depth of of this sacrifice why
wasn't ending g4x clam forcing the
opening of the h-file followed by brace
yourself Bishop to f6 exclam of iatch
Boomtown look at every piece is hanging
black can't take anything without
getting made it if you take up 6 we take
f5 by the way King takes allows Queenie
for checkmate rook takes allows rook
takes d6 followed by everybody entering
with gusto of course we're treating the
king would allow immediate move
like queen h7 the queen is just
infiltrating the h-file and the game is
over
so this this highlight here I spent a
lot of time on this position I'll be
honest with you I've probably spent more
time analyzing these games and is
considered healthy for any human being
neglecting my email inbox as we speak
because I had to know the truth
what's going on here this one I even
analyzed with Komodo and it takes Komodo
a while to come up with whites long-term
compensation but once they do you see g4
you see that pieces open up and come to
life and you see exactly why black is in
so much trouble so in the game stock
fish sees as much of this as he did and
plays King g7 all it all noted now is
really needed because he's getting the
King off of this sixth rank where all
those tactics were occurring preventing
the knight from getting developed so as
far as us understanding why these moves
were played that's kind of the goal and
I think we are Bishop to e4 comes anyway
again just a really simple
straightforward approach I'm gonna trade
pieces to open up lines of attack Bishop
to g6
takes on East g6 and then queen h3 shows
again the difficulties that black
continues to have even with pieces
coming off the board
I'm keeping such a strong eye on the d7
squared that this night remains crippled
whether it's because the Queen will come
in the rook will come in too many
potential threats for black to have the
time to develop the Queen side that's
the whole point
Bishop f6 King to g2 now we're switching
over the H file a lot of people had
analysis here here stockfish took a2 and
we're gonna see that the attack really
gets going for alpha zero now because of
the H file but I wanted to prove that
probably this position is already beyond
saving anyway even if work h8 was played
here's why the Queen comes into e6
actually no that was the that was the
line I analyzed that's not as good I'll
show you it was Queen e6 there's
actually a line that goes into the
endgame that goes like this
Queen f8 rook d6 Queen f7 forcing a
Queen trade and the combination that I
analyzed with comodo was that a big
trade here followed by Bishop d4 check
would win the rook but likely the result
here would be a draw maybe even black is
the only one who can win despite the GG
pawns and due to the healthy
three-on-two on the Queen side so that
was the first line analyze but actually
Queenie sixes is not needed white
doesn't need to be that forcing and the
simple Queen to g4 is enough for White's
attack to still be just devastating for
black the knight still can't develop
because the rook comes to d7 and simple
moves coming
whether it's Bishop D for Bishop takes
g5 and blacks position is is not really
savable
I'll show you one line we analyze which
is Queen FA takes on g5 rook h5 f for
Bishop takes pawn takes c5 what allow
Queen e4 and again you're looking at
positions where there's just okay I
guess if you don't play C five and
Queenie for the threats are things like
rookie six and rook d6 and there's no
way to guard the the infiltration of of
the g6 pawns well we'll come back to the
reasons why moves like Queen to f7
trying to come in on this diagonal are
no good because of the brilliant idea
that alpha zero found in the game I
don't want to spoil that for you so I'm
not going to show you now but we can see
that with the opening files and simple
moves white is gonna maintain a strong
attack even if black had played rook h8
that's the proof in the pudding we were
trying to find what that line so after
King to g2 again Rock h8 wasn't played
Queen takes a to was rook h1 the Queen
comes back to g8 and this is the last
moment where we see alpha zero is full
picture brilliance come to the table if
you haven't Paul if you haven't seen
this game maybe pause your video and
think about how white can improve on the
attacking chances without allowing
potential counter play against your own
King because you need more pieces in
order to open up all the necessary lines
that it'll take to get out this King but
how to do it without opening counter
play
that's what alpha 0 found here and when
I first saw this move I was like why
that seems like a weird computer
movement that I was like oh that's why
and that move was c4 I love this move
because exactly the first question is
why is that needed what's the point well
the first thing it points out is that
it's very crucial that the Queen cannot
capture because Queen h7 is made if the
Queen could capture c4 would be just a
useless computer move where you're like
you know WTF why the face but there's no
c4 if the Queen can take it the Queen
can't take it because of mate so what's
the point in inducing the pawn to come
to see for the pole point is that in
every line after B takes c4 suddenly f4
is a possibility where it never was
because now there's no longer a queen 8
to check White has literally closed down
the highway with blacks own pawn
allowing white to be super aggressive
with the threat of F takes G 5 and Black
has no counter play line we looked at
was if takes Queen h6 check King of 7
followed by Queen takes here again if
Night Moves rook d7 is coming after
Queen to g7 Queen takes c4 check Bishop
to c5 I don't even need to go on you see
the evaluation bar flipping there's
Queen e6 check there's rook e1 check
coming black is simply busted so again
none of that happens without this
amazing idea of f4 and it's exactly what
for stockfish to see the writing on the
wall suddenly black goes into panic mode
where it wasn't before in fact even here
you see still likes black but very soon
after rook the rook to e8 we're gonna
see that White's attack becomes
overwhelming and even stockfish knows it
Bishop to d4 making another trade not
because we're happy to trade pieces up a
piece but because elimination of
defenders is the key way to break down
blacks obstacles takes d4 takes d4 rook
da trying to close the defiled and Queen
e6 though we'll see that now the lack of
pieces you basically cut the board in
half yes White has been playing down a
piece this whole time but really White
is playing up an entire rook as far as
evaluating who's threatening what the
idea of Queen e5 check followed by
Brooke h7 is is mate which is what
forces Knight to d7 finally to be played
but with the rook coming to d1 white is
gonna win not just back the knight but
with it even more material that's what
forces Knight c5 the point is that if
white allows if black allows rook takes
d7 as we said it's not just the knight
its seventh rank mate which is why black
had to go for the endgame down the
exchange white simply trades starts
picking up all the pawns that he can
emphasizing King activity though again
alpha zero just having good Russian
schoolboy technique all around never
falling for any traps of course
stockfish trying to set a few more like
forking the king and rook alpha zero not
interested gonna make the right choices
to solidify tactics before gobbling up
all the Queen side pawns and when he
does black will simply throw in the
towel and that's what happened here
after king DD for now the threat of rook
takes b5 is unstoppable
again one let's remind her you couldn't
take it because the knight wood fork the
king and rook but every king before
stock has just resigned so back to that
final critical moment where the knight
did come to d7 I just want to want to
make sure that we've proven to everybody
exactly why why there was nothing better
than Knight to c5 again no Queen move
will avoid will avoid taking and and by
the way no reason for white to try to
keep the attack going when you can just
convert into
I found that again just very human very
human characteristic very
straightforward approach from alpha zero
simplifying as soon as he could no point
in doing this even if you get even if
you win the night on on c5 because as
soon as black is able to kind of bring
more pieces into the into the position
even if pawns fall to check you're just
happy that you're black you've been able
to stop the mating and net and probably
you're gonna draw this Queen and pawn
ending that's that that's exactly why
alpha zero made the right decision to go
into being above the exchange so all
right well that brings our entire video
series breakdown of the alpha zero match
versus stockfish to a close we hope you
enjoyed it thanks for tuning in to all
of our breakdowns if you want to see a
quick highlight maybe this is the only
video you've tuned into and you're not
exactly sure that you have time to watch
all the other 15 to 20 minute breakdowns
head over to my youtube channel
youtube.com slash Daniel wrench please
follow me over there and see a a faster
breakdown of just the highlights the
real critical moments that took place in
this match the key positions not entire
game reviews either way I appreciate
everybody tuning in to this series
thanks for thanks for supporting the
chest community and we'll see you around
on chess calm